surtout la réalisation qui transgresse
toutes les règles du cinéma de l'époque
tournage caméra à l'épaule faux raccord
montage nerveux regarde spectateurs
allez vous faire [__] le film est une
révolution esthétique et narrative et
remporte un succès immédiat c'est le
début d'une période prolifique pour
Jean-Luc Godard avec un film parent et
de nombreux succès comme Pierrot le fou
ou en 1963 le mépris et sa scène culte
plus que tout autre Jean-Luc Godard
aurait incarné la nouvelle vague et ses
provocations Jean-Luc Godard est devant
un provocateur dont vous aimez bien
étonné par exemple bah non mais je
trouve que
si les gens sont endormis et qui a des
choses qui font du bruit bah ça les
réveille s'ils étaient endormis dans les
années 70 Godard qui a participé
activement à Mai 68 se lance dans un
cinéma plus politique et ce marginalise
avant de retrouver le succès dans les
années 80 avec sauve qui peut la vie
tout au long de sa carrière le cinéaste
Nora cessé de questionner les limites du
septième art des innovations pas
toujours saluées par la critique
les films que beaucoup d'autres
n'osaient pas faire ou du moins n'oser
pas se lancer et alors il me respectait
quand même où j'étais célèbre parce que
quand même José me lançait il y a des
moments ça me haïssait aussi à cause de
ça avec la disparition de Jean-Luc
Godard la modernité qu'il a tant
incarnée appartient désormais à
l'histoire du cinéma
et tout de suite c'est l'heure dont on
va plus loin
[Musique]
et c'est donc l'heure dont va plus loin
comme chaque soir 20h40 on revient
ensemble sur deux infos marquantes de la
journée regard croisé ce soir de nos
chroniqueurs Bruno Darou de la rédaction
de France 24 bonsoir Bruno et Marie
Roger Billois présidente directrice
générale de l'Africa International Media
Group bonsoir merci à vous aussi de nous
avoir rejoints sur ce plateau on va plus
loin tout d'abord ce soir on en parlait
il y a quelques minutes sur la situation
très tendue toujours dans le Caucase
après ces intenses bombardements de la
sorbaïdjan sur plusieurs villes et
villages d'Arménie notamment sur
dermoopa negories dans les régions
frontalières du garage konic et du
sionic le Premier ministre arménien
dénonce une agression de Bakou fait état
d'au moins 49 soldats tués côté
Arméniens de son côté
l'Azerbaïdjan affirme avoir rempli ses
objectifs et parle de 50 soldats morts
pour sa part la France je vous le disais
à saisi le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU
de nombreux pays appellent à une
désescalade on va d'abord écouter le
porte-parole de l'armée azerba avez
suivi du Premier ministre arménien
dans la nuit des groupes de sabotage des
forces arméniennes ont profité des zones
montagneuses et de la présence de ravins
dans la zone pour déposer des mines sur
différentes routes d'approvisionnement
utilisées par les forces
azerbaïdjanaises
sont une réponse à une soi-disant
provocation de l'Arménie mais nous
sommes en mesure d'affirmer que ces
informations sont fausses et n'ont rien
à voir avec la
réalités Bruno tout d'abord sur ses
bombardements il ne concerne donc pas le
hoaraba on était habitués donc à des
escarmouches sur ce territoire disputé
entre l'Arménie et la sorbetjean mais
cette fois on parle bien du territoire
souverain de la République d'Arménie
c'est un cap qui est franchi oui d'une
certaine manière parce que effectivement
comme comme vous le dites très justement
il ne s'agit plus de la faire du au
Caraba qui est donc un territoire en
majorité peuplé d'Arméniens qui se
trouve
entouré par le territoire azerbaïdjanais
mais là ce sont les forces
azerbaïdjanaises qui sont entrés
quelques puisqu'il y a visiblement eu
des forces spéciales qui sont entrées on
va le voir sur la carte voilà dans les
trois villes que vous citiez donc à
l'intérieur et parfois même bien à
l'intérieur du territoire arménien
notamment concernant jermouk donc là
effectivement on peut parler du fait que
de ce point de vue effectivement une
forme de de cap a été franchie alors
vous avez entendu le ministre
azerbaïdjani la défense qui dit que
évidemment c'est s'étire et ses
opérations ont été décidées suite à des
opérations de sabotage qui ont été
menées par les soldats Arméniens quand
on connaît la faiblesse de l'armée
arménienne ça paraît franchement peu
plausible enfin bon nous ne sommes pas
sur place en tout cas les Arméniens eux
parlent carrément on entendu le Premier
ministre pachinian de faux prétexte il
faut rappeler d'ailleurs c'est le même
genre d'argument qui avait été utilisé
par l'Azerbaïdjan quand il avait
déclenché son contre le haut Karaba
Auger que cherche à obtenir
laservadjoint à travers cette attaque et
bien déjà on peut dire que laserbaïdjan
choisit bien son moment
les Alliés c'est une région très
compliquée surtout quand on est
originaire de la partie sud du continent
et c'est il faut rappeler que c'est une
zone qui n'est pas en paix depuis très
longtemps c'est à dire entre l'Arménie
et l'Azerbaïdjan ça fait des dessinés
des conflits à la suite de
l'effondrement de l'empire soviétique
dont les deux parties faisaient dans les
deux étapes faisaient partie donc ça
fait un moment que il y a des tensions
et là Bruno rappeler que en 2020
c'était pas le premier de la série
il y a eu encore une attaque de
l'Azerbaïdjan mais qui sait très bien
terminé pour elle le azerbageant ou la
azerba
en tout cas ça s'est bien terminé pour
ce pays puisque
il a récupéré des territoires qui
appartenaient à l'Arménie donc il y a eu
des médiations mais ça a amené on pense
évidemment toujours à l'Ukraine mais ça
se terminait que le pays agressé et
c'est lui qui perd du territoire et donc
là en ce moment les Russes sont sur le
terrain soi-disant donc pour comme force
de paix et quand on écoute ici et là ils
apparaissent comme des alliés de
l'Arménie mais en face on a la Turquie
qui soutient
l'Azerbaïdjan et qui est encore qui a
encore probablement sa main dans le jeu
en tout cas il y a quelques temps la
France avait demandé à
mon président turc de cesser
d'interférer
dans ce conflit là bon donc aujourd'hui
puisque la Russie comme on l'a dit aussi
et très occupé en est très mal barré
probablement plus tard dans son compte
dans sa guerre d'agression contre
le l'Ukraine c'est le bon moment pour
obtenir sans encore des concessions
territoriales m'a érogées parlait Bruno
du timing opportun donc
utilisé par l'azor bedjan cette attaque
intervient aussi quelques semaines après
la signature fin août d'un accord avec
l'Union européenne on se rappelle
d'Ursula vanderline qui parlait de la
norvégien comme un trust World partner
donc un partenaire fiable pour la
livraison de gaz alternative au gaz
russe donc en lien avec
la guerre en Ukraine qu'est-ce que vous
inspire aussi ce timing
le président Alif doit se sentir la
position de force parce que non
seulement effectivement les Russes sont
très occupées par ce qui se passe en
Ukraine ce qui n'a quand même pas
empêché la Russie de réagir assez vite
en tant que partie médiatrice entre
guillemets entre l'Arménie et
l'Azerbaïdjan elle a annoncé avoir
obtenu un CC qui visiblement qui
visiblement n'a pas n'a pas tenu très
longtemps ce matin puisque les échanges
se sont poursuivis dans la journée même
avec une moindre intensité et puis
effectivement le fait que la présidente
de la Commission européenne sous la
forme vers la hyène se rendent en
Azerbaïdjan pour alors on comprend bien
le souci des Européens face au chantage
à l'énergie de Vladimir Poutine il
cherche à diversifier leur
approvisionnement notamment en gaz mais
effectivement cette visite a été quand
même critiquée par certains partis
certains responsables certaines ONG sur
le fait que bah déjà c'était pas
terrible entre guillemets de se
rapprovisionner en gaz par un régime
comme celui de Vladimir Poutine enfin
c'est franchement pas mieux concernant
le président
quand même est loin très loin d'être une
démocratie vous évoquiez le soutien de
la Turquie indéfectible à laserbaïdjan
quel rôle joue vraisemblablement la
Turquie dans ce regard de tension en
tout cas qu'est-ce qu'elle a obtenir
déjà la Turquie est un grand client elle
reçoit beaucoup de gaz de la verbale
Jean
est un pays riche comme on le sait il
faut le rappeler il est beaucoup plus
important comme partenaire que l'Arménie
avec qui la Turquie a des conflits
historiques on sait autour du génocide
et donc il y a pas une seconde
d'hésitation pour la Turquie choisir son
partenaire son allié dans dans cette
dans ce conflit bien précis et donc là
ils sont même en phase active souvent
parce qu'il y a certains certaines
alliances qui sont passives mais on les
a vu
soutenir très physiquement même des du
matériel dans ce qui s'est passé dans la
guerre à la guerre et
actuellement aussi je crois que le
président alive et le gouvernement
azéri a dû faire le tour c'est très
important cette histoire de gaz en ce
moment ça fait partie du contexte que
ils sont grands les grands
ils livrent du gaz à l'Europe ils ont
été adoubé par on se lave anderleyenne
Moscou est occupé ailleurs et non ce
qu'on redoutait à un moment donné c'est
pour ça aussi que la guerre en Ukraine
est stratégique et qu'on est et que les
gens ne souhaitent pas que
les les
Ukrainiens perdent c'est parce que il y
aura des phénomènes d'opportunisme comme
ça pour voilà élargir des territoires
attaquer des pays qui semblent en plus
mauvaise posture et justement Marie
Roger on va plus loin aussi ce soir sur
la situation en Ukraine ce qui en train
de se dérouler marquera-t-il un tournant
dans le conflit l'armée ukrainienne à la
faveur d'une double contre-offensive
lancée fin août et début septembre à
reconquis ces derniers jours une
vingtaine de localités soient 6000 km²
dans le sud donc près de la ville de
Carson mais aussi dans la région de
karkiv qui est qui bénéficie d'une aide
militaire renouvelée de la part des
États-Unis inflige visiblement de
lourdes pertes matérielles et humaine à
l'armée russe peut-on Bruno déjà parler
de Tournon dans cette guerre c'est
peut-être un peu tôt quand même d'une
part parce qu'il faut voir
l'ampleur qu'aura cette contre-offensive
à la fois dans le sud et à l'est si les
Ukrainiens vont réussir à conserver les
territoires qu'ils ont au conquis et
surtout s'ils vont faire face aux
véritables visiblement d'après les
informations qu'on reçoit ici des luges
de de tir d'artillerie que leur inflige
les Russes en riposte donc les Russes
ont dû se retirer physiquement si vous
voulez avec leur char leur blindés etc
ils redéploiement c'est ça
retirés et du coup il
bombarde des villes comme carquises
notamment ou loubian ce que notamment
depuis depuis 24 48 heures donc la
situation reste quand même assez
instable néanmoins d'un point de vue
psychologique de la guerre si vous
voulez c'est quand même très important
que les Ukrainiens puissent présenter
des contre-offensives réussis alors sur
au total disent les Ukrainiens 6000 km²,
ça représente dans un pays comme
l'Ukraine 1% du territoire national donc
ça peut paraître peu mais les endroits
où ça se passe ce soit autour de Carson
au sud donc enfonçait en coin vers
l'arrière-pays de la Crimée qui est
absolument stratégique pour les Russes
et puis surtout à l'Est aller de plus en
plus apparemment il serait allé jusqu'à
la frontière russe au risque peut-être
de menacer l'approvisionnement de
l'armée russe par ses bases arrière en
Russie ça c'est quand même
stratégiquement assez important mais
disons que la situation reste encore
volatile n'est pas fixée donc faut
rester prudent en tout cas sur le
terrain l'aide militaire des Occidentaux
et notamment l'aide de militaires
américaines récemment renouvelée change
la donne c'est sûr que c'est très
important même si j'ai été amusé de
d'écouter un militaire un officier
ukrainien qui disait non non pour cette
phase précise ce n'est pas l'armement
américain c'est pas l'armement de nous
allier qui a été décisive c'est c'est
tout ce qu'on a pu récupérer des Russes
eux-mêmes parce qu'ils ont abandonné
beaucoup de d'armements notamment des
munitions absolument donc bien sûr que
ça joue mais je suis absolument d'accord
que il y a une espèce d'euphorie je
dirais plus dans les médias que chez les
je dirais les dirigeants européens et ou
américains occidentaux vis-à-vis de
cette phase où la l'Ukraine a repris
niveau de terrain bon il faut bien sûr
rappeler ce qui se passe au début de la
guerre ou
la Russie c'est enlisée tout de suite on
se dit ça y est les Ukrainiens vont
gagner on a vu que c'est pas le cas mais
quand même même si ce n'est qu'une phase
de la guerre est qu'on sait pas ce qui
va se passer demain on part on parle
même de déjà les Russes vont peuvent
devenir très méchant parce que il est
pas question qui perd de cette guerre
mais quand même ceux qui ça montre c'est
que c'est une armée qui a de sérieux
problèmes structurels l'armée russe et
et quel que soit le cas on voit la
différence entre l'armée ukrainienne qui
est très collaborative on a vu ils sont
très inventifs ils sont toute la
population la population participe d'une
manière d'une autre qui sont très
moderne et le disons la direction le
commandement russe très rigide opaque et
qui pense que la propagande couvre tout
on a vu les limites justement de la
propagande ils ont ils ont beau déclaré
non tout va bien on voit bien que tout
ne va pas bien et qu'il y a des
problèmes sérieux et on peut penser
effectivement que ça ça peut être un
tournant sérieusement la guerre c'est
compliqué et nous on est je suis pas une
stratège mais on voit quand même que il
y a quelque chose de particulier à cette
même c'est important c'est pas beaucoup
mais psychologiquement et avec très
rapidement ce que vous disiez c'est
quand même juste en un mot sur le fait
que l'armée ukrainienne est structuré de
manière beaucoup plus moderne avec des
officiers intermédiaires et donc des
capacités d'initiative des commandes qui
fait que c'est des unités très mobiles
et puis par ailleurs c'est une derrière
c'est une nation en arme contre un corps
expéditionnaire venu de l'étranger avec
effectivement à une manière de commander
entre les généraux et les soldats russes
il y a quasiment rien donc du coup c'est
très lourd et c'est très rigide et c'est
pas très efficace merci beaucoup Bruno
merci à vous aussi Marie Roger pour vos
éclairages respectifs ce soir d'envoient
plus loin donc sur la situation toujours
tendue dans le Cauca ainsi que sur la
guerre en Ukraine merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce module l'actualité continue sur
notre antenne restez avec nous
[Musique]
l'essentiel de l'actualité européenne
un débat où s'affronte les pires et les
meilleurs élèves européens
un entretien exceptionnel avec un grand
invité
ici l'Europe présentée par Caroline de
Camaret